what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today um i'm gonna talk to you guys
about
a topic that i've been asked a couple
times um
a lot of guys on the channel they'll say
how are you so reasonable
or even girls they'll ask me like how
can you listen to this man
talk about all these women being average
and all these women
um you know um
not deserving these great guys whatever
and i have one
one answer for you
low self esteem
um from a young age i haven't thought
highly of myself
i never thought that i deserved
a lot to be honest um i never thought of
myself as a queen
um and i never thought of myself
super highly i'm gonna i'm gonna just be
honest here
from a young age um i was what you call
humbled okay um
most of my friends right were generally
like more attractive than me like if you
look at my closest friends especially
when we were younger right you know
way it starts to play a part when you
get older but especially when you're
younger i was never the hot friend
now i'm not saying i never had female
privilege it's a thing
you know but most guys
even the average guys you guys talk
about
so dearly if they were interested in me
they would ask me about my friend first
and if that didn't work out then then
they would come crawl into me
so yeah
i would say low self-esteem um that's
the main one
and yeah being humbled
that's why i can listen to man of sphere
content